welcome back to GameSpot's III
prediction show right here on the lobby
Daniel drew are joined by Chris waters
now we've got marking Gaston from the UK
say something in an English accent oh
hello Thank You Martin and of course
Justin hey old as well yes thanks bot
news editor gentlemen lexan you have a
wonderful a wonderful cool accent and
also use to it and you know lots of it
Sony which is why you have you here
we're gonna talk about Sony predictions
they'd had pretty good III last year is
that fair to say they did is right haha
it's still amazing that people are still
talking about that and you know that the
PlayStation 4 is just kind of still
going from that momentum of basically
trouncing the xbox one and like
everything that xbox said in their press
conference you know Sony just came out
and said I'm no DRM yeah you want to use
used games we're gonna do that also
here's the price and it's a hundred
dollars less than their system and it's
still going strong so isn't it didn't
wasn't the more maybe much of a case
that last year also need really did was
react to what Microsoft did badly well
they didn't even have to react they just
went we're gonna stay the same you know
the things you can do on PlayStation 3
that's also a PlayStation Florida's
we're just not gonna blow it like
Microsoft did all right and they didn't
know they did not blow it the best thing
I heard it Ethier Leslie the best and
it's probably not even true Attaway is
that there was like a hundred different
slides for that last slide of the price
they had rehearsed all kinds of prices
cuz they were just sitting there waiting
really for the actual price so they had
it today they could have gone parade
down to five dollars to a million
dollars they have slides but all of it
and as soon as Microsoft put it on there
like right to do that one no one with
that and I don't know if that's true but
I want it to be true because that's the
spirit that Sony has now and I love that
it's a maybe it's more like in sitcoms
where you fill multiple scenes of an
angle or multiple angles from for a
different scene with different
characters just so nobody really knows
except the person on stage who's kind of
reveal well like even the the trailer
they had where they did the how you
share games with your friends where it
was Adam Boyes and shoe just handing the
game to each other girl that was
recorded the day before the press
conference in the backstage area behind
the stage you spoke about that at games
coming
and that videos got like millions of
views that sits put into perspective
like sony has teams and teams of people
who work full time putting together
promotional videos and spending millions
many millions and they they sit in
meetings for like weeks and weeks going
yeah I guess work though this shot
whether this shot and then suddenly
these two executives go look like boo
and the view couch she's like 19 million
views or something on YouTube incredible
I mean do you think they could get away
with just staying the course you know
with showing the same kind of ratio of
big games to indie games to play station
now to you know living room stuff and
then could they just sort of carry it on
and not not losers lose their footing
well for me the PlayStation now price is
something that's going to be really
important and that's some place where we
don't really know what xbox is going to
do they've been talking about making the
xbox one compatible with you know
previous games and Playstations answer
has been whatever PlayStation now is
going to be whatever that price is going
to be and if it's something you know
that's tied in with PlayStation Plus
which we already have a subscription to
like that'll be awesome and that will be
a huge bombshell like you just have
access to these games because you're a
plus subscriber making that even sweeter
but if they make it something if xbox
comes out and says and we're gonna make
all of our xbla content available if
you're an Xbox Live subscriber but
playstation goes and here's a separate
service and its twenty dollars a month
but you get access to old games that
that's not going to be quite the same
all right in fact let's talk about the
actual games the first party stuff that
they can bring to disable first of all
I'm a talk tomorrow matt drive clear
this is you we went over to the studio a
couple of weeks ago but it's a runcorn
where's Ron core it sounds like a plan a
railing to Liverpool really yeah nice
how was that cool did any of you play
drive car busty no okay I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be honest it was bad okay last
fast year or recently last year at e3
last year it was a bad game okay it
wasn't fun the Hanlon was all messed up
and it just didn't it didn't have
anything so when they well I good when
it come to Uncle and play driveclub hmm
I was like yes but well I last pay this
game was very good and of course better
now whatever and say you know we go up
there and I'm playing it
I it's actually better now it is better
now now I find hashtag drivi club
hashtag drew the club at mine the whole
thing about it a bit difficult yeah like
I don't think with all this like social
thing I don't think that actually really
matters yeah like I think that's to be
expected now that's like a an expected
feature yeah multiplayer in some aspects
like leaderboards itself is like part
and parcel of driving it yes sir leading
on that I think's a bit silly because
everyone's going right oh yeah yeah
whatever yeah driver Torres sure life
and at least the drive attar things it
is something like that's something new
so that same fort sir has but the the
handling of driveclub was was really fun
mm-hmm it was it was a fun game to play
and i want it i really want it to do
well because i also believe that if it
doesn't do well but this is really hold
on yeah they are do they need on another
driving franchise like that they have
gran turismo anything he does all the
arcade stuff they have one gran turismo
every 17 that's and in 20 29 when they
do it's gonna be great well but there
were these two demo versions first full
price range prologue and pro-black yeah
that's what they'll do uh but i think an
arcade eraser it's a good thing to have
likes the last neither speed mm yeah and
there's not one coming out this year i
think a first-party Arkady racer it's a
good thing for sony to have in their
stable yeah if you will allow me to use
that probably horrible executive mullet
what's the big one now is it like is it
deep down or is a project beast or is it
like is it last guardian cuz i well yeah
all I keep hearing is the last guardian
is like well because they are we luck
with set for this year this is like the
seventh year that they haven't talked
about the last guardian but this is the
one year where it sounds like it
actually might be so it's either there
this year yeah or it's got or it's not
yes totally yeah okay they either they
either took it away a couple of years
ago and said guys make it a ps4 game and
PS try not to you know not finish it
again or it's gone yeah that is what I
believe I don't know but I'd it must be
that month that makes sense right yeah
that makes sense so it
it's gonna be there that would make
sense why hasn't been here exactly why
they held off exactly but if it's gonna
be there it's going to make a splash I
mean you could show something that is
essentially no longer or more
complicated than what we saw so many
years ago and I think people would still
freaked out with delight and
anticipation because they're finally
getting it dude I would feel so well
okay like oh my god I'm freaking that's
one of the things that makes this show
so exciting though is that you know
amidst all of these leaks that we've had
that battlefield hardline all of them
yeah the whole trailer for that to come
out so many of these games we already
know about where Sony like what are
these Studios working on have so many
internal studios are they keeping it a
secret that's awesome just got a
question here from Mordor who's asking
new god of war what do you think like
water so many Santa Monica working on
they have to they've got Corey back
Corey okay anyway yeah Cory Booker
actually there are eyes by rogue I
always don't I wish I always know it's
time miss Barragan I'm like no Barrick
is is that that is rates territory
Mortal Kombat mystic is a character I
must be wrong with that damn but notice
they've got hit that he's got him back
he was like the god of war to do the
Khan award to his the best one okay
here's the others yeah he's got a rotten
is said to have him back is really good
and I want it's being uip like I want to
be I mean moving though the spiritual
successor or something but like God more
quarter got a piece goddess of war god s
fine got gonna walk carding fine to sum
up like something new but they they've
got him back and that's gotta be
exciting well we talked about exclusive
so much with Microsoft I mean what are
the Sony exclusive uncharted other Wars
a huge one and of course uncharted
wouldn't were like all but guaranteed to
see you yes significant amount of don't
forget what this untried now they've got
the they've got Neil druckmann and Bruce
Straley back yeah they're overseeing it
they can now go from the creators of the
last of us oh yeah the traders are the
last of us the new one shot up exacting
what's happened now is the last of us is
is the bigger game yeah I think its core
cachet was good core gamers anyway I got
home gonna know the crazy but I don't
want more last of us like I want that to
be a standalone experience that's the
chair that
that was a great experience now please
do something different only they're
pretty much like on opposite ends of the
spectrum as well ones like this
bombastic action trope you know or you
know adventure and then the other one is
a depressing slog uncle other so things
are gonna be able to take from that that
work really well in the last like the
shooting mechanic a mechanically it's
wonderful putting those in uncharted
like Oh finally please finally you're
gonna fix all these things that really
you know what you are you want Drake to
be more of a like really got to work
hard to like land a shot not his like
freewheel and like pop it up I don't
want to walk into a room in Joe style oh
here's 50 enemies that you have to kill
an event for 40 more yeah discuss making
of walk in a room and killing 50 enemies
will Derby new kill zone this year no no
no I hope not long cuz I don't like
Killzone what a gorilla working on that
they've been working on you IP for ages
okay like they've been saying oh we've
got our new RP guys this for like twenty
ten and they've been doing this a long
time so glassy good Last Guardian it's
actually sell gas it's just going to
accept now it's actually the guardian
animal thing is actually some sort of
nazi and yet they let you blow up its
home planet but you're the good nice
meeting you where its head so it doesn't
matter that story worked really well for
killzone i don't see why they would not
well yeah the rich fiction of his own
that it's so hot right now yeah super
hashtag decide because i'm coming soon
okay dark souls ripoffs project-based
deep down maybe it's unfair to say that
about those games project-based no no it
can't call it a rip off its from from a
shop where it's from from from proper
yeah it's the most exciting game i've
seen in ages and all I've seen is some
witness yeah so more China leaks I am I
am so ready to the game and that's
that's a very III game if you ask me
because you know I mean all of us in
there watching III will you know that's
the kind of game that is would be made
to appeal to us that is again you know
Todd's its value with the newspapers
someone she'll be doing back flips
around the game spot you get so agile
whenever dark souls is mentioned that
won't bring his mind if that happens and
spelunky to is announced for a visa
he'll might just lose his goddamn mind
I'm trying to think what else and well
one thing I don't think we're gonna see
it all is project Morpheus we saw that
you know yeah
you think they're not gonna show much do
it at all no I if they do maybe it'll be
over at the booth like here's you can
try out the thing that we showed off at
GDC but so for the people don't know
this is their virtual reality headset
proprietary one that they're making
themselves has there been much in a way
of like discussions about how that is
that going to be specifically for the
PlayStation yes sir like are they gonna
go to the PC Roche is it be they haven't
talked about it a lot I would assume
that this is going to be a playstation 4
only kind of device this isn't gonna be
coming to pc but you know we don't
really know cuz it's only though if
they're doing that then they're gonna
have to like the connects they're going
to have to make software reasons for
people to buy it like they're gonna have
to start making games that are made
either specifically for or at least are
additive with the with the Morpheus do
you see that being a section in the
press conference maybe a lot of how did
the press conference like I think the
press conference is going to focus on
the more immediate then now in the 2015
and this stuff isn't going to be ready
by 2015 even oculus ism nothing will see
any more fees in fact what I think we'll
do is though they'll talk about how well
the PlayStation is done but having slide
no they can't do the numbers thing again
they stopped doing that last year where
they said only nine minutes of pie
charts they'll run the owners they will
just go their numbers are too good not
so yes so 9 million notes because I mean
honest miss me for over nine million
[ __ ] and sold yeah and then they will
just move on so they'll update with that
and I talked about how you know they've
got the present sorted and there will be
a bit like and we're also you know we're
investing in the future and then like a
Morpheus thing will appear in the
background and yeah sort of making it so
they'll move on sir laurence fishburne
look I'm out sitting on a chair that
does not look dissimilar to this one a
man can say yeah well he likes to shell
last year there was a bunch of weird
indie games that came out of nowhere
that shadow of the beast announcement
was the strange thing okay it's coming
in my life at Gamescom what other wit do
you think there's gonna be any more
weird indie gasthof oh absolutely it's
all gonna be triple-a bindis now but i'm
wondering is there gonna because there's
a lot of indie games that at the moment
of like like no man's sky which nobody
knows what platform they're coming out
on do you think it might be the thing
we're about microsoft and sony are going
to try grab some of those for time and
exclusives I really do no definitely
Indies were such a huge part of their
messaging last year they're going to
continue to embrace that I think we're
see even more cool indie stuff that they
both Microsoft and Sony have been able
to snatch up and I really don't want it
to be exclusive I wanted to come to as
many platforms as possible because I
want to be able to play it on everything
well I think the phrase timed exclusive
is totally one we're going to hear a lot
or at least is going to be true about a
lot of games this year because I feel
like with so many of these indie games
you're past the point where I one
company is just buying them out right
yeah you know there's like look on the
balance you know if we can get
exclusivity for the first three months
and that's when people are hyped about
it that's going to give us a significant
share and then you know who knows what
the the business logic is behind it for
the creator and for the publisher but I
think timed exclusives are much more a
thing that you see with this caliber
game and certainly something that both
those these two big publishers are going
to be leaning hard into for III but just
when you'd have like geometry was too
and shadow complex and other games i'm
forgetting because there's lots of
lights on me Oh trials HD you know there
when summer arcade was good it was so
good and I long I know this is the sony
bit but just for either of those things
you know maybe Sony can have autumn of
PlayStation Store or don't know but like
solid ball full-size in number i don't
know what's good until till we get there
like those in the games you have to try
out like you see the demo and you're
like well that's kind of quirky in front
but then you played you're like oh my
god is so awesome cool all right
gentlemen thank you so much for coming
on talking a bunch of Sony mess
Microsoft and Sony probably going to be
the most interesting added to it i'm
especially after what happened last year
you